[Music]
straight ahead on Long crime daily the
Russ movie said shooting is back in the
spotlight our ocean investigators have
determined that rust production failed
in their obligation to provide a
workplace free of recognized hazards but
first complete coverage of the Johnny
Depp vs Amber Heard defamation lawsuit
after you said let's drown her before we
burn her Mr death you said I will her
burnt corpse afterwards to make sure she
is dead disturbing text messages
revealed when death is back on the stand
plus how Depp says herds abuse
allegations affected his career I lost
then
no matter the outcome of this child I'll
carry that for the rest of my day and
later I called her slim and she called
me Steve which was
Lauren because and Humphrey Bogart's
nickname could a once romantic pet name
Make Way for a herds courtroom wardrobe
we take a closer look at the internet
Theory long crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer
cross-examination gets heated as Johnny
Depp takes the stand for the third day
long crime Network's Jesse Weber was
inside the courtroom Thursday he joins
us now in Fairfax Virginia to break down
the back and forth of cross-examination
thank you
Brian so cross-examination began with
Depp admitting that abuse can take many
forms not just physical but also
emotional and verbal something that Depp
admitted to because he was abused by his
mother in the same way now that's
important because Amber Heard side is
saying that she was abused by Johnny
Depp in a multitude of ways and that she
was not lying about him in that
Washington Post article from there we
heard attorney J Benjamin rottenborn
who's representing Amber Heard leading
Johnny Depp through that alleged abuse
particularly through a series of text
messages they tried to show the jury
that Depp was potentially violent mean
degrading and of course had a very
serious substance abuse problem dep in
these text messages called himself a
monster a Savage someone who would spray
rage and even in another text message to
someone threatened to smack Amber Heard
They even played audio of death on that
Infamous flight from Boston to La where
he is groaning and moaning this again
reinforcing that he was potential really
violent and also that he was the one not
Amber Heard who torpedoed his own career
through his behavior this included
showing up late or even destroying
property which is something that Depp
admitted to under cross-examination and
they even presented a text message from
Johnny Depp to Amber heard's Mother
where he admits that Amber Heard helped
him through the detoxification process
which is something in stark contrast to
what he testified to under direct
examination so Depp is clearly in the
hot seat but how much this is going to
hurt his case or help Amber heard's case
that's something we'll just have to wait
and see Brian
thanks Jesse on cross-examination Depp
admitted to pass physical violence and
later some disturbing text messages he
sent
you've trashed hotel rooms before simply
because you've had a bad couple days and
an unpleasant time correct I have a soul
to the couch or two yes sir you'd agree
that at times in your life you've
expressed yourself through destructive
Behavior
um
yes and you'd agree that at times when
you were angry you smashed things up
right
more in my um
confused sort of Youth yet you text Mr
Bettany let's burn Amber 3x exclamation
points right you see that it gives you
the
and at this time June 11 2013 Amber is
your girlfriend or perhaps even your
fiance at this point correct
the girlfriend yeah for sure and and you
didn't stop when you said let's burn
Amber you say let's drown her before we
burn her three exclamation points did I
read that right yes
you didn't stop it and you said let's
drown her before we burn her after that
you made another comment and and I'd
like to apologize to the court and to
the jury for some of the language that
I'm going to have to use today but
unfortunately
um
you're going to see a lot of documents
with language like this
after you said let's drown her before we
burn her Mr Depp you said I will fuck
her burnt corpse afterwards to make sure
she is dead
that's what you said that you would do
after you burned her and after you
drowned her did I read that right
you certainly did yes and you wrote that
about the woman who would later become
your wife
yes it is
joining us today is trial attorney
Krista Ramey and co-host Terry Austin
Krista how does arguing Deb's career was
on the decline help heard's case is is
she proving that point because we've got
at least a hundred thousand people
watching daily that say otherwise
well if his career was on the decline
then that anything that she wrote would
not have caused any damages to him so if
there was in fact defamation the the
fact that that there was a decline in
his career could be blamed on a
multitude of other things including his
excessive drinking and drug use which
was well known at that time yeah it'd be
interesting to see all that maybe maybe
Deb's lawyers kind of Twisted I'd say
this accelerated it I don't know but
that's a great Point Krista Terry these
drowned and burn texts and some of the
audio recordings that we're hearing as
well does that change depth's image in
your mind do you think it will make the
jury believe he is capable of hitting
herd because of these messages
you know what the language doesn't
change my image of death and I don't
think it changes anybody in the jury's
image of depth listen they know that he
has this unique and distinct vernacular
he uses curse words he speaks in
hyperbole he uses imagery you can't take
everything he says literally because he
doesn't actually mean he's going to
drown and burn her he doesn't mean he
wants to see her body in the back of a
Honda Civic so I think for a fact that
he uses language that can be offensive
but it's not language that I think will
change the image that people have of him
I think they understand that he's unique
in this way and that he doesn't mean all
of the things that he is saying yeah and
another Point too if if he's saying this
when they were dating as girlfriend and
boyfriend or fiance he ultimately
married her so obviously those are not
true feelings as you said uh Terry
probably hyperbole but we'll see as the
case continues still had on Law and
crime daily our coverage continues on
Johnny Depp versus Amber Heard after the
break what led up to the depths back and
forth cross-examination and how he says
heard's op-ed has affected his career
[Music]
welcome back our coverage continues now
in the Giants have Amber Heard
defamation lawsuit ahead of Thursday's
cross-examination Deb pinned Direct on a
strong note explaining how the
Washington Post op-ed has affected his
career
did you experience any consequences
after the release of the op-ed
what were those
oh I will
I believe it was uh I
don't think it took
Disney very long maybe a couple of days
to
announce that
that I had been
um removed from the Pirates of the
Caribbean
films franchise
opportunity this way no matter
the outcome of this trial
the second the allegations were made
against me
the accusations
the second that more and more
of these things as I said metastasized
and turned into
[Music]
father
for the media
um
once that happens uh
or once that happened
I lost
I will live with that
for the rest of my life
because of the allegations and because
it was such a high profile case so I
lost then
no matter the outcome of this trial
I'll carry that for the rest of my day
a brief cross exam on Wednesday Heards
attorneys asked about Deb's career
post-abuse allegations and pinpointed
what event led to his legal action
and you aren't aware you said pirate six
in your view is dangling you're not
aware of if or when pirate six will be
made correct
and the fact is Mr Depp if Disney came
to you with 300 million dollars and a
million alpacas
nothing on this Earth would get you to
go back and work with Disney on a
Pirates of the Caribbean film that is
true Mr rottenborn and you spent a long
time talking about the impact of the
abuse allegations
um made in misheards obtaining the
temporary restraining order in or the
domestic violence restraining order in
May 2016 right
sure and you said you testified that you
wanted to fight it right
but the fact is you never fought the
allegations in court in 2016. it was
only after misheard published this op-ed
in 2018
that you that you fought them you never
tried to fight them in 2016 did you I
was advised by my attorneys not to fight
thank you
if I knew Disney was paying alpacas I
would have asked for more Terry this
seems this cross-examination seems a
little messy with this op-ed was it
something else that that destroyed his
character his uh career or or him uh do
you think this is going to lead us to
seeing a lot of redirect recross back
and forth to kind of iron out these
details
well I hope we don't see a lot of that
but we might listen The Watch
watch op-ed was just the culmination of
all of these events their problems began
when the relationship began or not long
afterwards they started out in 2012 and
Heavenly Bliss and then about a year
after they started having these
accusations going back and forth and
certainly by 2016 when she filed the tro
things were very messy they got the
divorce and I think that's when she
started making these accusations of
course the op-ed post is the center of
everything but he's going to have to
demonstrate how everything led up to
that and how the statement he made
wasn't really something that was true he
made it because his lawyers told him not
to fight the tro so we'll see what
happens but I think it has to be cleaned
up as far as depth team is concerned
yeah Krista now if this is a big if I
don't want people thinking this is going
to happen but if herd's attorneys prove
it wasn't the op-ed that lost debt the
ability to work with Disney could this
case end before Amber Heard ever takes
the stand
you know it's a good point first of all
I think that Amber Heard will take the
stand regardless of anything I think if
I were Prosecuting this case I would put
Amber Heard On In the case in my case
and cheat as representing Johnny Depp
it's not like a civil case you can call
any party to the stand or a criminal
case rather so you might see Amber Heard
take the stand immediately after Johnny
Depp or or shortly thereafter before the
planet closes I was gonna be interesting
to see if Johnny Depp's own attorneys
call Amber Heard it's going to be a
great TV and of course if it happens
we'll have it here for you uh thank you
both coming up on lawn crime daily our
coverage continues in the defamation
suit is Amber heard's court attire a
strategy and issue copying her
ex-husband's looks or those of a
Hollywood Legend we examine the fashion
Theory taking the Internet by storm
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we continue our coverage of
the multi-million dollar definition suit
where Hollywood X's Johnny Depp and
Amber Heard face off in Fairfax Virginia
the case getting record streaming
numbers here at the law and crime
network has gained attention from across
the globe some fans now creating a
theory that Amber hurt is strategically
planning her outfits and hairstyles each
day she's in court last week eagle-eye
fans noticed a b pin worn by Depp to
court in the days following herd is
wearing a similar pin on her tie some
Fans Say herd is specifically copying
outfits worn by depth others say heard
is now dressing as famed actress Lauren
Bacall in direct examination Depp
testified he used to call her the
nickname slim based on a Lauren Bacall
character he says the pair consider
themselves similar to Lauren Bacall and
Humphrey bogar two famed actors who had
a similar large age Gap
thank you
I called her slim and she called me
Steve which was
Lauren because and Humphrey Bogart's
nickname
nicknames for each other in the in the
film that was their names in the film
um and it you know it wasn't also wasn't
lost on me the fact that uh
there was an age difference and that uh
um
my God When when when when Humphrey
Bogart and Lauren Bacall that's when
they met on that film he was 45 years
old and she was 19. I acknowledged the
the fact that I was the old pragy Bogey
and she was this
um
[Music]
beautiful
um
[Music]
creature
all right Terry since you have to
explain it to this uh Canadian
Millennial what's your take on this
Amber Heard Lauren bacallit Theory
because I'm not too familiar with who
she is
I think she's trying to look a little
bit like Lauren Bacall and frankly she
looks a lot like corn because she is a
beautiful woman you cannot take that
away from her she is a stunning creature
and you've heard testimony about the
fact she doesn't even need makeup she
wakes up looking like that I think it
was endearing for Johnny to talk about
the fact that he called her slim she
called him Steve he acknowledged the age
difference he acknowledged he's the old
groggy Bogey and so I do think it made
him look good and I think his image is
very similar to His Image in the movies
and so they're both sort of playing the
characters that they are and the
characters that the audience already
thinks of them and I think it could work
to their advantage to see Johnny Depp as
you know the captain and to see her as
Lauren McCall yeah and Crystal this is
interesting because I think we both
agree on this most seasoned trial
attorneys I know think long and hard
about what their client will wear in
front of the jury because as close as we
know say a lot any thoughts on what
you've seen heard and depth where and
what Impressions you think that could be
giving the jury
yeah absolutely you know first of all we
do we I've taken client shopping
um I think that um I think that they're
both dressing very smart and there's
some choices that they're making that I
think are are bad
um because you do want them to clean up
and present well to a jury so I think
that Johnny Depp suddenly pulling his
hair back into a ponytail I think worked
I think that his lawyers and his trial
team you know maybe pivoted after he had
his hair down the first day of trial I
wish that he would take off the the
colored glass reading glasses though I
think they're distracting and although
it is part of this image I don't think
it works here all right we'll see how
the the jurors interpret this and other
evidence that comes into the case uh
thank you very much both when we come
back the deadly rust movie shooting
months after the shocking incident the
state of New Mexico reveals its
investigation results what they say was
the root of the problem in the death of
similar photographer Helena Hutchins
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back actor Alec Baldwin says a
newly released investigation into the
shooting on his New Mexico film set
clears his name this after the film's
production company is fined for safety
failures
the shooting happened in the outskirts
of Santa Fe in October 2021. Baldwin was
pointing a gun at cinepotographer Helena
Hutchins while they were setting up for
a scene Baldwin said in interviews after
the shooting the gun quote just went off
killing Hutchins and wounding the
director Joel Souza on Wednesday New
Mexico workplace safety Regulators
issued the maximum possible fine against
Russ movie productions totaling around
137 thousand dollars the state's
occupational health and safety Bureau or
OSHA says their investigation revealed a
laundry list of safety failures in
violation of standard industry protocols
including the film's assistant director
handing the revolver to Baldwin without
consulting the onset weapons specialist
regulator is also noted the A.D took no
investigative or corrective action when
he witnessed two other accidental
discharges of rifles on set OSHA
announced the fines in a video release
our ocean investigators have determined
that rust production failed in their
obligation to provide a workplace free
of recognized hazards
more specifically there were several
management failures and more than
sufficient evidence to suggest that if
standard industry practices were
followed the fatal shooting of Helena
Hutchins and the serious injury to Joel
Souza would not have occurred the bottom
line here is that it was the employer's
obligation to follow national standards
and that did not happen on the set of
rust
well I realize novine can compensate for
the loss of life we are holding rust
Productions fully accountable Chris when
I hear that presser my my public
defender since it started tingling that
sounds like recklessness to me you're
not following industry practices so
could we see Reckless homicide or other
criminal charges citing this report in
the future
I think that it's even more than just
Reckless they the report noted that it
was willful and intentional disregard of
the safety measures that were in place
and you know that were there to protect
the employees I think that you're
absolutely right Brian I think that you
can you know see charges coming down for
the supervisors on the set the people
that acted willfully their supervisors
and that could include you know by the
way
um you know Mr Baldwin who is his
production company was you know an
employer on that very set so
um yeah I think that there is a good
possibility that you could see criminal
charges flowing from this yeah but Terry
Baldwin says this clears him uh of all
wrongdoing so do you think these results
do just that
you know I think it's ironic Brian that
he thinks that these findings clear him
of any wrongdoing I think just the
opposite in those findings you heard
them say that these are maximum fines of
course it doesn't bring back anyone to
life and it doesn't you know detract
from the fact that people were injured
but I think it saying overall that rust
Productions failed and they did not
follow industry standards and Alec
Baldwin is absolutely responsible he is
one of the producers on that set he is
the employer as Christa said he is
involved here he basically during one of
the interviews said that he wasn't
responsible for hiring but he is
responsible for hiring he's responsible
for making sure that the set is safe all
of the time and ultimately even if there
are no criminal charges there could very
well be some you know penalties as far
as the civil case is concerned yeah I
can see this investigation being cited
in a lot of actions around this case so
thank you for that and thank you for
joining us here on Law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
[Music]
foreign
[Music]